so Pizza Pizza it's a pizza I really
love pizza I feel like I could have it
like breakfast lunch dinner my uncle
owns a pizzeria Pizza is my favorite
food
I've been eating pizza probably like
three to four times a week
I've never faced a pizza that I couldn't
conquer
[Music]
Oh oh my god too much you can't beat a
sandwich there's a bunch of different
piece of pizza ception
its pizza inside pizza and it appears to
be a grandma pie with a regular pizza
and then some sort of beautiful crust
situation on top all of which are great
on their own and I bet they're better
together
ah Cheers it's ten times three
intimidating it tastes like a pizza
hybrid with a garlic knot I really took
tomato sauce it's like very light
through it look at all the garlic on
there yeah this is my kind of pizza
definitely have this sauce and cheese
right but it's just too soggy
Joey's this pizza - yeah it's pizza
they're giving to be a lot wait what
happens if I just oh that's not know
this I think I prefer the crust of the
bottom but I like the flavor of the
pizza in the myth this is like a lunch
pizza I'm like on the go the bottom
one's just a plate if you will a pizza
plate look at this is the appetizer and
see this is this is really this is just
like Oh like I know what I'm doing this
is garlic bread this is starting to feel
like 4:00 a.m. in college and you get
all the garlic smell so you're thinking
it's garlic bread and then when you eat
it you're just like really sad it's not
purchase more crust just gonna discard
this and go straight for the main course
pizza would be like the garlic pizza
with the crust from the bottom pizza I
would order this for every party I get
invited to for every part of your throws
have the normal pizza and wings this is
too much you just have a little bit of
everything going on here and it's
perfect man mmm this this is the
ultimate ultimate pizza box this I would
like to me yeah you're like choosing
your own adventure with this thing when
you're with a group of people and
everyone's like no I'm probably only
need two pizzas little do they know
surprise it's
not just with you
[Music]